and we're joined now by the irish prime
minister
uh on the occasion of the meeting of the
british irish
council uh meeting virtually uh i should
say
uh mijo martin is with us and tasha
thank you very much indeed
uh could i ask you first of all what the
outcome of this year is that
u.s presidential election uh either way
uh
means for your country for ireland
well as you know ireland um has a very
strong and enduring
relationship with the united states it's
a a very rich
and enduring partnership economically
socially culturally and of course
through our many many ties with families
and friends and
irish the irish american diaspora plays
a very active role
on both sides of the aisle and clearly
that was manifest in
in this fascinating election which has
resulted in
extraordinary numbers coming out to vote
uh and an extraordinary demonstration of
of electoral democracy at work
and uh obviously it's it's a very close
call and
trends are emerging in certain
directions uh but
you know we're looking forward to
continuing that relationship with the
newly elected uh you know uh president
sorry whoever gets elected in in in in
the coming while we're looking we're
looking forward to
uh working uh with that with that
democratically elected president
as a champion of democracy yourself
would you say
that it is right that every vote should
be counted in this presidential election
absolutely every vote should be counted
and has to be counted
and i admire what is happening and i've
watched it
with great interest over the last number
of days and
the organization of the vote and the uh
the
the attention to detail and the uh
affirmation by those responsible for the
counts
that everything that is possible is
being done to ensure the integrity of
the vote and
uh i think it is uh worth watching and
uh
i think it's very very important that um
as
broadcasters have continually stressed
the need to count every vote and to make
every vote count
now that of course is not what donald
trump is saying and does it surprise you
that
uh the spokesman for the british prime
minister
uh boris johnson has this morning
when being questioned by journalists
repeatedly refused to say
what you've just said that every vote
should be counted
well i you know i'm not responsible for
what others say i'm not
i wasn't privy to what you've just uh
said there but um
from our perspective you know that
relationship with the united states it's
the oldest democracy in the world
the irish did a lot to build america um
and uh through many many presidential
elections there
there has been an irish imprint an irish
um
influence and this election is no
different uh from both sides
uh the irish american diaspora playing a
role in both
uh campaigns and that reflects that
relationship i spoke to earlier but what
is clear to me though is
that people in america wanted to have
their say
they came out in large numbers those who
voted early in terms of million votes
and
those who voted on election day and
because of the coronavirus i think it
was a very wise way of
organizing the election in the manner in
which it was organized and i've watched
over the last number of days as best i
can you know on the tv screens and so on
but it's very clear to me that the
various administrators in the various
counties and in the
various states are doing everything they
can to
protect the integrity of the vote to
make sure that every citizen's vote is
counted
and that's the way it should be and
despite all
of what is being said uh i think that is
coming
through that is coming through to any
audience that's watching this
uh that this has been well organized
and um attention is being paid to detail
and people have
uh a route to redress if people feel
that they have issues and that those
routes to redress are there
now let's talk about the british irish
council with the uk
leaving the european union i suppose
this is going to be
the main body of collaboration between
the uk and ireland going forward
are you satisfied that there is
sufficient
coordination across the islands that we
share
to really deal with this coveted
outbreak
well i think to this morning's meeting
was very useful in that respect and was
um
hosted by nicolas sturgeon as you know
and first minister scotland and i think
we
worked and discussed the need for
greater coordination but also to share
each other's approaches
each other science data analytics in
terms of how we can continue
to get the right level of restrictions
that enables us
to keep our economies going and keep
people at work
so there's an acknowledgment that
there's an ongoing need for better
coordination
but that said there was no doubt this
morning
in terms of the degree of the impact of
covert 19 on our respective economies
and
the need really to keep on top of this
virus
and thankfully in ireland the trajectory
is now downwards
we're at the highest level of
restrictions here at the moment we had
been at a lower level
but we decided to increase the level of
restrictions
and the combination of the last number
of weeks is resulting in a significant
reduction in the number of cases we
still have some distance to go
uh we're on a six-week uh lockdown at
the end of november
started two weeks ago and we need we we
intend to keep the pressure on the virus
so that we can open up again in december
and beyond
into the months of january february and
march and hopefully a vaccine
will arrive towards the end of the year
that will give some hope to people
uh for 2021. now
as far as brexit goes uh donald trump's
envoy to brussels one of his envoys
has told journalists that the european
union
would be prepared to use cutting off
air travel as leverage
against the uk to try and reach
agreement uh over the current
negotiations
is that true i haven't heard that being
discussed at eu council meetings
uh normally done the margins of such
meetings and they've attended
some key meetings now in in the context
of brexit most notably on the 15th of
october where we had a
very comprehensive presentation from
michelle barnier i think my own
engagement with the president of the
commission and indeed with
michelle barney has been that europe is
very
focused on the intensive negotiations
that have now been underway for quite
some weeks and
negotiations have intensified to be fair
and indeed at the big meeting this
morning the british irish council
meetings this morning
i think secretary michael gov secretary
gave a good
uh presentation as well and i i think we
all expressed a common desire
uh that the optimal outcome now for our
citizens and
citizens and for those who represent is
to get a sensible
comprehensive trade agreement that
prevents any further shocks to the
economy
and further challenges to people so i
got a sense this morning that the talks
are continuing with that level of
intensity that is required uh there are
issues around
the level playing field in terms of the
uk has access to the single market
that there would be a uh level playing
field uh and also discussion around
fisheries
and the importance of fisheries that
sustainable fish stocks into the future
and of course the issue of governance so
i hope and my view is that as as as
politically represented as we owe to the
people that we represent
uh to ensure that common sense prevails
and that we get an agreement here that
protects jobs
uh and protects our respective economies
because we've had one hell of a shock
from covert it's been very damaging
to our economies covert has it's created
a lot of unemployment
the last thing we need now is an ordeal
brexit that would just add
significantly to that type of negative
shock uh which people could do without
now
finally tasha a domestic matter you'll
know far more about than i do
i understand it's been reported that
your deputy and of course
political rival dr leah veradka has
leaked
confidential medical information with
potential commercial value
to friends what is your response to that
well i think we dealt with that
comprehensively last week the
it refers to actions in the last
government um
when the tarnished and and leo vadcar at
the time
um he sent an agreement that had been a
rise up with the
representatives of the gps the irish
medical organization
uh to the head of the of another medical
organization which
hadn't been a party to the negotiations
he did so with a view to
getting the gp's support um for that
agreement
it was subsequently signed on by most if
not all gps in the country
uh he has apologized for an error of
judgment on
his behalf i have said that it was
the wrong thing to do wrong way to do
things it was not best practice
i think the tarnished or deputy leader
has
acknowledged that he has apologized in
the dial for that error of judgment and
that's
i think there was a very comprehensive
presentation to the doyle
uh this week on it okay thank you
very much indeed for that and thank you
for joining us uh
michonne martin the irish prime minister